And let's remember. So now we're moving
towards the felonaza.
It's a little more complicated field
than the cultivation set. Some of the
things that are there, the timing window
of the third drill is here. But more
importantly, that need for a constant
fluctuation
especially on the curve. So in the um
drill set things are linear
and there's no real need for a constant
fluctuation because the pressure doesn't
ever change in this vector. Okay. So
this is the drill of the c cultivation
set. But as I
start to move, I get his centers
pressing into me. So it kind of happens
by default, which is what makes it a
cultivation drill. But as as we're
moving, I am still moving that center.
So likewise,
he pushes. He's still going that way and
that is still being grounded. So he
can't go that way. So the rate you could
you could show it. The the rate is that
I am letting him in. So let's say he
wants to run past me. He he can't. He
goes in at the rate that I'm letting him
in. I control his rate. Okay. So
likewise if Sean comes around
and
I am not doing an anatomical
uh there's no skeletal
alignment here. You see? And so Sean's
added force. He just feels that same
back foot as he's not going to shove me
at some weird angle because I was
bracing on this angle. You see that?
Okay. So, uh, we'll just do discovery
learning
that way.
Okay. You control the So, the guy's
driving
and you decide the rate at which he
goes. the other guy's pushing on you and
you'll feel I'm doing everything the
same on the inside. So Sean can't push
that way
and Chris is is irrelevant to whatever
I'm doing. Okay, just to see what Oh
yeah, that's they took away skeletal
alignment there is this constant need.
Now how do you do two angles? You can't
do two angles with whatever we were
thinking in the linear applications.
Okay. All right. Try just to see what
you're experiencing.
You see that two angles like right away
you'll go, "Fuck, I was doing something
else." So yeah, that's good. As long as
we discover it.
Here. Uh, I can take we can go over
here.
You're not you're not following him. You
have a whole different job.
All right, everyone feel what we're
talking about? Okay, keep going. Keep
training.
And it's important like
I I just pick a vector. I'm not I'm not
in the I'm not in whatever he's doing.
You understand? So he his shoulder is
turning. I will turn around. That's
that's another vector. But I may touch
something over there.
Got it. Don't let my hands slip.
So I go, you can keep moving. I'm just
here.
Okay. All right. And you can see, whoa,
whoa, whoa. Just lots of forces are
acting on this. Okay. So that's why you
got to go back and do the other drill
way all the way through the the drill.
Okay. So,
so no even you can get them moving any
old way, but you have to in your mind
go, what was I doing in the other drill?
Okay, so I'm here. I don't pull on his
fingers. I should feel his center. The
quad is going to move the elbow. I feel
his center. That's what makes him move.
Okay. Not him pushing. I get out of the
way and I make him move. Okay. So, I'm
here. Feel this.
Boom. Yesterday we went here. This time
we're going here. Boom.
Boom.
Okay. Try.
So, start by settling your young aspect
down.
Connect to the center. Move his center
with the adhesion in the palm.
That's it. And don't get picked up like
that.
Feel
his center through the through the
movement.
Move your claw.
Constantly scan for tension for desire.
Constantly modulate back to that
midfoot.
You can't keep the same
orientation, so to speak.
[Music]
Watch. Don't tip your shoulder cuz
there's no way I can be on the back of
your foot with a dip shoulder. You see
that? Okay. So, try it again.
Okay, let's watch this.
So you're facing the shoulder already
going back. Everybody see that? If not,
I got to watch the video later.
Okay, stop. So why the shoulder go back?
Just now you guys stand there. You can
ease up on the pressure. Get back where
you were. There's a There's a turn. You
see it? Okay. Go back. Keep focus.
Keep going. Keep going. Keep going. Keep
going. Keep going.
Okay. Uh, now the shoulder's dipping.
Why is that happening?
No.
You're feeling a lot of pressure, Chris.
Right. So, in other words, if we're
here, let me go back to where you're
starting position. Get your yong going.
Okay. So, I'm moving the shoulder back.
The pressure. You see the pressure? Now,
it keeps going in.
His elbow is getting closer to his body.
Do you understand what what's making
your elbow get closer to your body? The
pressure. Got that? Try it again. is
you're looking at me like I don't know
what you're talking about. I've moved my
shoulder there.
There it is.
There. There it is again.
Can you guys see this? Okay. This is
really no different from yesterday. You
push in. You're pushing in. You see? And
so you're like,
"Oh, I gave you a couple options." Which
were the what was the first one I gave
you?
Turn over.
Not working. Not enough for my
grounding. What? Slide back. Okay. But
don't let your organization go. So we're
here on this one. Okay. and you're
feeling whoa I'm going over and long
before you felt that you should already
start coming into the movement. Okay,
try it again. If you if you go to the
spiritual level, why did I get pushed
back? Because I'm pushing in. Why am I
pushing in? I'm trying to keep control.
Okay, let's go.
We're we're now in Kihog. So you do what
it takes using the engine you have.
Watch your uh toes pointing out away
from each other.
All right.
So,
I have my grid
here. Where how much in can this elbow
go in the in on this spiral
to the to the yin? The hand can go to
the Wuji line, but it can't cross over.
Okay.
So here
I can hold that. So I don't need to
start. If I feel pressure, I just start
turning it already. Okay. And I move the
elbow to the inline and this hing.
was doing it earlier. Same thing. But
even earlier, I'm not getting out of the
way. See, I'm in his shoulders. Even
earlier, I whenever he's touching, I'm
moving the center. Making that center
move. It was here. It got to there.
That's all I need to traverse the mat
here in position. Okay. Leave it there.
Pull the shoulders. Not kazushi till the
shoulders pull on the center. Okay. Try
it again.
Pay attention to the elbow and the grid.
And make sure you get there, though.
You're on your toes.
So, it's too You should have turned them
earlier. So, I Let me Maybe I'm not
being clear.
In the coq set, we are training for the
skill. There's less application
in those things, especially like drills.
Let's take the standing meditation off
since that always confuses me. Okay, so
the drill one, we hold it, right? You
hold it. You let the pressure
accumulate. Okay, you're trying to
increase your skill. So you you hold as
much as you can, as long as you can. And
then drill two, we actually increase the
weight by making you go forward. Okay?
We're not doing that kind of training
right now. Right now, we're trying to
use not increase the engine. We're
trying to use the engine you have. Do do
you understand that difference? Okay. So
that means I know what I'm supposed to
do
and I should have never got here.
My engine got displaced right away, but
my engine should have gone here. Do you
get? So, there should be no time where
I'm shaking now or anything. But at the
same time, I'm still using the same
engine and still achieving the same
goals. Okay? Because
there's no such thing as your once and
for all engine
that's universally going to address
every that. That's not true. Not true at
all. Okay. different fighters, different
surfaces, different
times of the day, all that kind of
changes, but I still work the same
engine. Okay? So, I shouldn't see any
shaking, no compromisation,
no, they shouldn't be there. I shouldn't
be in their shoulders. Got it? Okay.
Let's put it all together in Khan. Now,
pay attention to the grid. Don't let
your Don't let him close your elbow
and don't fall out of your stance.
Get your elbow to the yin line and don't
let him take it past it.
Get in their center, not in their
shoulder.
Don't lean your right shoulder forward.
Don't lean onto the front foot. I know.
You know, Chiba used to do this all.
That's not what we're doing. Okay. I'm
not doing that. I b the back foot. He's
pushing. I ground the back foot. I stay
on the back foot. I'm not gonna come
over here like this. Okay. At this
point, there's no way I've passed the
grounding angle has passed the
contestation angle. Just keep going
forward. There's no way. He's brought my
elbow past that in line. Okay. Stay on
the back foot. Try it again.
The claw only turns a very small amount.
We're not doing hip rotation. It's a
very short, quick move.
Release tension the entire time.
Don't fall out of your stance.
Get your elbow on the grid. Use the
grid. We're going somewhere.
Elbow on the y in line. Wrist grabbed.
The muja is on the luji line. Bring the
muja to the line.
Don't change the articulation of your
elbows. The m's going to change.
The elbow goes inside your wrist. The
elbow goes inside your wrist. So, watch
here. I'm just going this way.
There's no this.
Okay.
This takes this shape because my claws
stay here. So if you want to, you can go
this way
and you would have the obvious outward
spiral. Okay?
But when my ball moves with it, it is
different, but it feels the same to me.
Me this spiral. Do you understand? It's
not this spiral, which is no spiral.
It's a flat circle.
This is a vertical circle.
There is a lot almost like you're giving
a to yourself here. Okay. Try again.
photograph to yourself. So you keep
feeling it.
Yes, that's it.
Wristed elbow and rotating around each
other.
Yes.
Wrist and elbow. Yes. Don't Don't go
over.
Angela, don't go over. This is the
natural hand positioning you're in. As
the wrist and elbow rotate around each
other,
just bring the elbow to the yin line.
Keep going.
Stop.
So you have to turn. You have to turn.
Okay.
Bring that elbow into that line. That's
it. Bring the mudra to your mid midline.
Stay grounded.
Weights on the back midfoot.
gets the elbow to the grid line. He He's
not my metric. I'm doing what's in me
and he's just a consequence of what I do
in me.
[Music]
here. So, this is
okay. When you're out there like that,
this is out.
Okay, that move's in this move. So, you
can keep working on that. This hand,
this elbow can't go to the Wuji line.
My hands will be, they can only be at
the Wuji line, which means this elbow's
at the in line.
So, I'm going to trade control points,
which we never do in the in the cookie
cultivation section. It's more
complicated. Yesterday, we traded it
from this hand up to the neck. This
time, we're training it to the other
hand. So, he's driving. I'm seizing. I'm
here at the midline, and I take my elbow
back out to the young line.
Same thing. I'm not trying to just get
his arm.
I pick up the adhesion here
again. Inch an inch kazushi
here. Half inch kazushi. It's It'll
work. Okay. But I have to try for it.
One here. Midsection.
Pick it up. Okay, try it.
Don't reach across yourself in the
middle.
Make contact with transfer in the Fuji
line.
You do move back to the arm.
The elbow back.
The elbow does come back through the
arm.
So you got this path. Here's where you
can make space. If we make you take this
cross and it's over here, there's
congested here. And you'll be congested
here on this bridge. Okay. So this is
where you touch it and that is where
from there you keep teasing and you keep
going.
You have to keep seizing. You got to get
out of the shoulders.
Find it.
Hey, go to what you know.
If I stop,
remember if I stop them,
then the energy stops. The very energy
I'm using to supplement the energy work
I'm doing in the cultivation set. So
here, I don't want to stop them. You're
you're going to see if you stop here,
that is going to be as every bit as
subtle as when we did the fingertip
pull. But if you keep the transfer
going, you're going to see there's more
energy. There'll be more yawn value.
There'll be more adhesion. The easier to
get the position. So like yesterday,
when you're bringing this, this hand has
to be ready. So you can't get them there
and then go here. This hand has to be
ready. Okay. Go.
Get that hand ready.
Yes.
[Music]
Remember to keep your weight on the back
foot.
Yes.
Always feel for their center on this
transfer over the control points.
Don't stop the energy.
Change primaries.
[Music]
Good morning.
Don't over rotate. Now our feet are
pointing out.
Okay, he's coming in.
Okay, try it. Maybe it was my slow exam.
I went slow so you could see my
movement, but you have to keep him
moving.
pop quiz. Where's your adhesion point?
Where? Wherever I touch it. Okay. So,
don't try for an area. is that's where
we're stuck. That's where his center is.
That's where I keep going. Okay.
Don't overtate.
There's only one movement and then we're
not moving anymore.
Thanks, Ryder.
Keep it moving.
Okay. So because we're moving towards
keyhon we get we have to stick more of
the shape in there shape becomes
relevant because we're more closer to
the marshall field and that's why we
have that grid here's where you can
transfer transferring across that is
going to open you up to cross body
checks. You never cross your elbows
across that towards that center line.
You're done. Okay? That's just a martial
universal rule. So I never do that. My
arm is always that's as far as my elbow
goes. This can do it, but not my elbow.
Likewise,
um, when we're on the outside of the
arm, pay attention to where you feel
this. Okay.
[Music]
Where is the last touch point? Above the
elbow. It's got to be above the elbow.
Can't be down at the wrist. It can't be
down here. If you went down by the
wrist, what happened to your elbow?
It's outside the outer rim. If I'm at
his elbow, I'm at my shoulder. Okay? And
this way, he can't
trap around me. Okay? Because I'm
controlling the elbow point, which
controls the hinge. So that wherever you
touch, yes, but you'll let that slide
wherever you need to to get back to that
elbow point. Okay?
Keep it moving. More and more energy.
More energy
[Music]
ground.
Move him. Move him past you.
Okay. Or structural question.
So here, that's what that hand is doing.
I only have this. I only have this. This
hand can't go like that. That's no
shape.
So this hand is going here. This hand is
going this way. It makes contact and
then it just moves. The elbow goes up
this way.
No. Okay. Uh, other thing technically to
get out of this wrist,
we'd have his arm somewhere like this,
right?
So to get out, it's going to get out
with that inward spiral.
It's not going to get out slipping this
way because I don't have that shape.
So this ad is going this way.
This way
back
then you put it all together.
Okay. Try
for the inward spiral. We already know
how the wrist and elbow rotate around
each other from yesterday.
Keep the center moving on its initial
trajectory.
Keep it moving in that direction.
over the top.
[Music]
Keep them moving. Keep them moving. Keep
them moving. You got to make that center
go in the shoulders. Keep it moving. We
got too tight.
The first one also moves. First one
moves into
turn it. Turn it.
So if if I am doing the outward spiral,
does that make sense?
And if I'm not doing the flat circle,
you guys see that what I mean by flat
circle.
If I'm doing the hour spiral and I have
the adhesion, you'll watch his elbow
wrist change relationship. Do you see
that? Stop. There's that same thing we
did yesterday. The hand is outside the
elbow. If you do the flat circle, the
hand stays in alignment with the elbow,
which means the elbow is anchored and
there's his power, which means you're in
the shoulders and not in the center.
Okay? So, I know we do that all the time
or we see it all the time. But here, I
can't get in. Okay? You have to take
that boom this way. Okay? Does that make
sense? And again, if you're just working
in with you,
you're that's all I'm doing. I'm just
doing this exercise. Okay? And then he's
just
whatever he's inconsequential.
It happens. Okay? Try it again.
In Khon, shape matters because we're in
Marshall.
You have to get their elbow inside their
wrist.
That's it. We want to come over the top.
So in this version, over the top, right?
Have your transfer guide ready.
[Music]
That's it.
Keep them moving. So it was hard to keep
them moving. So what should I do instead
for my engine?
The last part was hard. So what should I
what be my solution? What should I do?
What? What should you do?
You stop. You stop him there. Keep it
moving. Keep it moving. This has to be
on the clock. It can't go.
It has to be on clock. Boom. Okay. Try
it again.
There you go. Okay. Radically different
result, right? Yes. Okay. Go.
You're late. Sean,
okay. So, you're late cuz you're there's
no room. Okay. Now, let's figure out why
there's no room. Go again.
No, no, no. We're not going slow
anymore. We need the amplification to
get the true human reaction. What do you
do? What you do right away? No. Pay
attention to his head. Go.
Do you see the little U? You see the U?
He's trying marriage with gravity. He
felt he felt my weight onto his feet,
but he he's trying to paint it with his
marriage with gravity instead of send
the energy down to your feet. He'll go
down. I didn't go down with you. So now
when you come down, you got to come back
up to get there. Too late. Okay. Try it
again.
Don't ever check your own height.
Keep it moving.
[Music]
Good. This is very, very good training,
Chris. Very good training. Keep her
moving. That's it.
Release the desire.
Don't move your stance yet.
Don't step out of it. If you're still
adhering, you're still staying still.
Try to get to the elbow.
It's got to be kind of like your back.
Your back's exposed. It should freak you
out. If that elbow is not inside the
wrist, it should freak you out. I mean,
you should let go. That this is not
going to work. Uh, and if you're on
below the elbow on the outside, it
should freak you out. These things don't
work when you learn the hard way. Okay.
All right. So, he's I'm going to do it
slow, but remember, we're not doing it
slow. Okay. I He's coming. I move him.
Here's that angle now
where I enter
again on that 90 to it. Okay. All right.
All we're doing is stepping. Just step.
Yeah. You got to get over here.
Don't grab nothing. Don't go. Just do
what I did. I just stepped in.
That's it.
[Music]
This way.
So, we got too far that your your elbow
came to Wuji instead of the grip.
Got to get there earlier. Your second
hand is late. Okay. Under. Over the top.
Over the top. Over the top.
Over the top.
Over the top. There you go.
And you want to go straight north.
Got to get it past you.
Straight
too early.
That's it. Relax.
Get your young aspect on your own self.
That's it.
Okay, let's fine tune a little. So, in
the same way that he's moving,
this hand is already here.
This hand is already here.
Touch. I'm already shifting weight for
that.
In other words, you can't go there after
it manifested because it takes time to
get there. Okay? So, likewise here, I
can't go there by the time it
manifested. Just like I can't catch, I
can't go get that ball over there. I got
to be ahead of it. Okay? So, same thing.
The hand is already moving towards it so
that it gets there and my body is
already shifting till I get there. Okay?
Can't wait. Likewise though, you can't
go early. You're going to take have to
take some of your Bang because it never
opened up.
Is moving moving and I'm here and I'm
look I'm rotating
in this circle that I'm creating. I'm
not passing.
So you should end up
spine your spine is just to the inside
of his spine. This is not enough.
Definitely not enough. Find his spine.
Not enough. Just to the inside of his
spine. Okay, try it.
And it's yin space, so it should be an
effortless movement.
Too close.
Don't use your grip.
When you get there, your young aspect is
grounded.
You go wherever it is.
Get in the back.
[Music]
Find the center first. There it is. Keep
it moving. There it is. Just step.
Relax. Relax. Rel
your leg. Get your hand ready.
Put it up. Put the other hand up.
Relax. Relax.
Okay.
It should be like this.
I'm already ready.
Okay, try it again. I don't want you
touching him when you enter.
Just step over there and stand.
Go ahead.
Find the center with that spiral.
Keep it moving. Keep it moving over the
top.
Good. And let go of it. I mean,
mentally, too.
You
and don't fall out of it. Settle into
it. Settle. Let go. Settle.
Let go. Settle.
Let go. Settle. Just settle. Let go.
Let go. Stop touching.
I go ahead.
[Music]
more.
Okay. So, um
again, these are things you know, right,
when you're fighting people that want to
kill you or want to get away. I know
this looks like you're in the back. You
know what I'm talking about.
Um but this is a quick a quick out. So
now I'm not saying
if we're here and he uh does not turn
but I turn now I'm not either. So
usually what happens is this is where we
are and then he will come with me. You
get it?
But at that turn he's not. And as I keep
turning, I even if I bring him with me,
he's not
I brought he moved when I moved, but now
I'm clearly not in the back. Okay.
So to do this,
this will kind of work. It'll work
further in the radius. Here I am spy to
spot. Okay. And I turn and I'm staying
with him. And as I keep turning, no, now
we're not. Now I'm not.
So like all things in fighting,
you got to kind of have
preparation for the failure rate and the
contestation.
So you're over here. So now when I turn,
he stay he stay with me. No matter how
much I turn, I will not get back onto
this angle over here. Okay? So, in this
drill,
I am going to
go past what you think is the back. And
so, the metric I gave you was here's his
spine, here's my spine. You see that?
Okay. All right. Try it again.
[Music]
You got to move him past.
You got to get on the elbow.
And in this drill, we're just letting go
and emotionally too.
And we only get one ED, right? Not two.
Not two steps. We don't get two steps.
We don't get two steps.
That's it. Yep. Perfect.
Release more back there.
Slip.
Keep the center moving. Keep it moving.
And release.
Only one step.
Okay. Uh, a general rule that we have is
like the barbell. I expect it to act
like a barbell until I put it back on
the rack. then the bar I don't care what
the barbell does. So the same thing with
my UK. The nag decides when the UK is
out of the technique that UK doesn't go
I'm out and leaves. Maybe I'm not done
settling. Okay. So the nag decides when
or out. You can either move and he can
see that you moved. He heard that you
moved. You can tap them whatever. But
they're going to hang out there till you
get to where you're doing the drill.
Okay. Go.
And at this point, we're letting go.
You're just way too close.
Relax everything.
get your spine where it needs to go. And
also, we're not touching them anymore.
You didn't bring him forward enough. So,
you had to go more towards 1:00. You
want to come towards three.
You got to not touch it.
And you should be in. She's in tie.
[Music]
This is it. This is it.
Release that glute tension.
Keep them moving. Keep them moving.
She's in tight.
Not Han me.
Definitely not that Federite Han me.
Your arches always are up regardless.
She's got She's got to get so that you
can enter.
[Music]
Got to get that hand ready for you. I'll
put it over here. Okay.
Yeah. Do what it takes to get things
motion and keep moving.
See, you go way over on that line. And
now there's no room for that hand.
over the top, not under the underneath.
So, a couple things. Let's Let's do some
uh discovery learning
for going underneath. You You can't do
this. Get on. You can't do get on.
You're fighting yourself. No rude. Will
he let go? Has I touched him in the
behavior cube? And will he go? Yes, he
will. Okay. But no, no one else is gonna
let you come up like that. Okay. To to
go underneath this hand has to come pass
through to another. So it starts here
passes then I have the same thing. Okay.
So
no,
we're not doing that one anyways. So
already here we'd be contesting but
prior to that we're contesting the
teacher. The teacher said we're going
over the top. So we let go of past
performances and we go over the top. We
let go and we release all anxiety,
tension, everything. My spine is over.
That's just where I hang out. That's the
drill. Okay, let's go.
[Music]
See where your elbow is right now? It's
at my feet so that I can't get in.
There you go. But we
release all tension. your glutes.
Remember, your problem areas have been
told to you. So, go there as a good
person wanting to improve. I'm going to
pay attention to what was brought to my
attention.
You got to move her.
Okay. Release. Release.
release onto the mid. Okay, you got to
be cool though. Like I can't I can't
get a release and then we're there for
10 years. Okay.
All right. Another um
discovery learning here. Okay. So,
normally he's not even pushing. He's
just standing there. Okay. And I want
you to get your spine to the back of his
spine on the other side.
Okay? Does everyone see that? Okay. Try
clear the hand. Get to the back.
Shuffle.
You need whatever. Don't push. Just grab
and get back there.
Yeah. There you go.
Don't push.
Do it two ways. Just do sugashi. See
where you get. And then the next way,
take as many steps as it takes to get
back up and count how many steps it was.
You're you're not doing my version now.
You're doing the old version we all
learned. Okay. We're doing it two ways.
I do sugashi
and then I do as many steps as it takes
to get that spine where we had it.
And remember the UK is not pushing,
just standing there.
as many steps as it takes to get you
there. Then try it with your sugashi.
You could just open your grip, too. They
would
just open it now and stay there.
Okay, now you're going to get you're
going to uh do the sukashi version
because
okay and he took three steps. It's only
one foot.
Okay, that's three steps.
Okay. Wherever you're at, that's where
you're going to hold on. Let's hold on
the shoulders. Okay. And you're going to
turn.
Okay. Got the idea. Okay. Go.
[Music]
Turn. Turning to your left
nag.
Turning to your left.
No. No. You got to do sigyashi.
Okay. So I what what I see is like I
can't even get you to do it the wrong
way right now because your body goes
this is actually not going to work. But
you're not conscious that you're trying
to get it to work by letting go of the
old way. So, I have to hold you to it.
Okay. So, we'll have this team come out.
And Angelo, you're the dog. Okay.
How many steps? Three. You only get two
in. Okay. Why do Why do you think he
wants three?
There's no nowhere near the back on.
You get that? Okay. So you only you only
get to do this. Okay,
that's all you bring. Yep. Yep. You can
bring this one up, but you can't move
the other one. Put it down.
Hold your shoulders.
Okay. Now, this is what this is what
happens when we don't pay attention.
Now, what we're going to do is move her
from the outside of where she is to to
my center.
Now, she's there. You understand?
That little distance, that doesn't
happen in real life. Okay? That's just
cuz she's been taught to wait. It's
better. You get to wait here and then
let me move you where my center is. But
originally, you were off center and I
used muscle to get you to center. and
now do the technique. Does that make
sense? Okay. So, that's what I want you
to experience that they're off center.
That's where I wanted them. Okay. Try
it.
Sean, you're going to hold on and then
you're going to turn it.
You only get two steps.
Then bring her to your center.
Yes.
There's your power.
Okay. Now, let's uh
give some physical
leniency. So, he's way taller. He's got
a lot bigger staff. Okay. And uh
Get yourself in the back.
Okay. Did Did you see that step? No. Is
that step natural? No. Is that Is that
ever seen any athlete do that and be
ready to do something else right after
that? No. Okay. It's just too
compromising. All right. Um, so even if
I could get there, I have even with this
variation, it's now not marshall
anymore. It's not natural. All right.
We'll do this exercise now.
Okay.
So, I was just standing still and just
hold me, right? Okay. Well, now let me
move forward.
Try to try to get to the same place.
Okay. Yeah.
Got got the idea. Okay.
So, he has to do Yashi that way.
He's going to do the technique.
Am I
No, I just walk.
Okay. Try it.
You're going to try to bring that.
You're going to try to hit that to your
center. Do you understand? You're going
to try to get to your center. I just
want you to do it at a walking pace
right now.
It might get you, it might not.
You're you're going to try to hold on
and try to turn them to your power arc.
Hold on. Turn them to your power arc.
[Music]
Okay. So even if you could not get a
grab, you got a good key grab or or
whatever, you can still feel the the
contestation, right? Okay. So if we if
we can, we'll just up the energy a
little bit. Okay. So instead of just
walking, I'm now running fast.
Okay. Try it.
I've done a good job. Really?
You got to try and get the shoulders.
Okay. So, we get kind of a shoulder grab
going on here. We'll watch.
Okay, so we kind of got it. Kind of. But
how did we get there? Let's look at it.
Where is he actually entering now? Over
that way. Do you see that? So again, to
me, this is
it. It looks like you want to go. I got
it. But you proved my point because you
had to go that way. You can't go that
way. Your body didn't want to do it.
Okay. Does that make sense? Okay. Um,
but even if we got it, I'm now chasing
someone and trying to stop them. I'm
still contesting. It's not the art.
Okay. And then from the Marshall point
of view, okay, you got my shoulders. Oh,
no. Here we go. Back back in. Double
lift. Okay. Um, it's nowhere near the
vulnerability we think we're going to
get from all that other stuff. Okay.
So, I'm not I know you might smell
here, but I'm not doing that in I am
trying to generate the centrifugal
energy
here very incrementally
that I now use my body
to start it too. Do you get that? Okay.
And so now you see that the fight is ro
has rotated because we rotated here. We
war
oppositionally.
We're going to do what we do on the
inside on the ten on the hands. They
feeding each other. And how do you do
that? You rotate the cross. This is
where I am now. Okay. In this technique
though, I don't want eating an argument.
I just want this concept.
Okay, you want this. Try it again. Let
go of the pass.
And that last angle, uh, Rio, that's the
right angle. Do it in here.
Step behind them. Yes.
Yes.
Get right behind. Get their spine right
behind them.
[Music]
You got to get his elbow to come in so
that you get some semblance that you
rotate that way. Okay.
The rest you do with your in
some semblance going that way. Like
instead of six, he's like at, you know,
6:00, he's like at 5.7. Okay. Just
slightly that way, which happens when
you make his elbow low like that. Okay,
there it is. And then you're there all
the way. All the way.
Yes, that's it, Rio.
Yes.
All the way. He has to pass you before
you can enter.
You got to get all the way to the back.
I don't know how big a step it is, but
your spine has to get there.
[Music]
Okay. So, if you're
if you're doing the the technique and
we're doing the last drill,
you'll see he's already on your P.
I'm good.
I get myself
there. I am.
So when I'm doing this, I get my back
here and we all turn together. You'll
stay in the back of this. Okay, try it.
You can do it slow or quick. What you'll
notice is Yeah, there's no more pull on
my hands. And I actually got there.
Okay, try it.
Make sure your spine aligned as
suggested.
Turn your spine with his spine. Right.
That's it. That's it.
You want to stay in the back?
Yep.
You You reached up. You got to do it in
the sequence. It's building up to that
move.
You got to eat the You got to dip your
fingers in the water bowl, right? Then
you got to eat the canopies. Then you're
going to have your soup. You can't go
right to the main course.
Be ready when you get there.
Keep him going. No, you just keep going.
He's got to pass you.
Keep him going. Keep him going. Enter.
Turn your spine. His spine will turn.
You shouldn't feel it in your hands.
[Music]
Be cognizant that you are in the back
through the entire rotation. Your spine
is behind their spine. At no time are
they going left or right of your spine
or coming from left to your spine.
You're staying right right behind him.
the the entire time I have to move you
past me, then I enter and then I turn my
spine and I stay behind him. Okay, try
it.
That's it. That's it. Keep your spine
there. Keep your spine there.
Keep your spine there. Don't go left to
right.
Keep your spine behind him. Turn your
body.
[Music]
I'm here. Okay. And I'm going to turn my
body.
Turn. Stay behind.
Stay behind.
Stay behind him. You're on the side
again. Stay behind. Stay behind. Don't
think you're naga. I don't do naga on
the shoulders. So, this is not an ibag.
Okay. But the concept is I'm in the
back. That's what we're working on.
Stay behind.
[Music]
Stay behind. Stay behind. Stay behind.
Good. Yes.
No pull. You don't want any off.
turn
on the half.
[Music]
Don't turn back the other way.
Okay. So, again, I'm not
just working on the concept with my
club. Uh, just get here. Okay. You're
here like this. I'm going to turn my
body. Turns his body.
And I keep turning on him. As you see in
the spiral, the way the spiral works,
the centrifugal energy is doing one
thing. Centrial energy is doing one
thing and he's losing his space and
support. It generates yin space. And so
yin space comes up. That's when I follow
him down. I don't shove him down against
the yong space. Does that make sense? So
that's why we're here. That's why we're
never going to go like that. Okay.
I'm just here and we serve my body.
There's like this and he I just follow
it down. Okay. Still not even but the
kazushi is. Okay. Try
no y no y in the hands pulling away. No
y in the hands pushing down.
Don't pull back.
[Music]
Okay. So, uh remember there's no forward
inertia in the technique.
Does everyone understand that? Okay. I'm
just not doing it myself. So, I'm here
like that. I turn.
That's what I'm looking for. Okay. Uh,
you can't get the exact kizushi because
we didn't let him keep coming in. I
don't have that inertia there. Okay. But
I can still do the 90 fluctuation to
his base support from the back, which I
can't do from the side. Okay.
Stay
back. Stay back. Stay back.
Don't let it go left to right. Keep it
on the bi line.
I turn. You turn.
That's what I'm doing. You see the
spine? I keep that.
Okay.
You want to pull him back.
Make a dance out of it.
See that pull
starting it. Starting it.
That pull there. That pull there. Don't
do it. Move in your hands. Okay. You
connect your spine and
turn. Stay in the back. Okay. Keep
going.
Turn.
No. Back. You're not You got on the
side. Okay.
Pull back.
Yep. Trust it. Trust it. Trust it. Yes.
Okay.
Turn with it. Turn with it. Just stay in
the back. That's
turn. Turn. That's it.
Let's do let's do do something to uh
appreciate the box. We're good to Okay.
And I'm going to use the same uh
downwardness
of the cook. So, I don't want to pull
him back.
I'm going to push him down this way. And
I keep sending his butt to the ground.
Now he's gravity's working against me.
I'll show it for a little bit. Okay,
there it is. Okay,
so we'll do it again.
I'm in the back.
I can't be on the side. Have to be in
the back
because I want this full I want his
trachea in the middle of my arm.
Okay. Boom. Pop. Pull. Not enough. But
I'll take the bar arm in this case
here. I'm chugging him forward with poke
here. It's It's like this,
but I have to choke.
Now he's falling into the bar arm. He'll
tap. Okay, let's do the bar arm.
Tap early. Let go quickly.
You have to be in the middle. You got to
tap early. You got to let go quickly.
You got to use your ground. You got
Don't pull them backwards.
Don't pull him backwards. You got to
ground that button.
Okay. So, you have to show his feet out
that way. You see, you're doing that
with your foot.
Okay. You pull someone backwards.
You pull me backwards. I just move
backwards. You kiss me.
You said my center out you. That was it.
That was that right there on the crush
on the trace. Okay. So on him I went
down. I went down with him. So you got
to still protect each other. But the it
doesn't matter. The projection is his
center that way. Okay. Not back. Walk
him backwards. Okay. Try it again.
[Music]
Grab the back foot and project that
center forward. Don't pull him
backwards. That's it.
And you have to be in the back for this.
Yes, that's it.
You got aim for center. You missed it.
There you go.
Get a good base. Get a good base.
Yeah. See how he wants to sit on you.
You don't want him to sit on you.
Don't kneel down. Let go. I'd rather you
let go.
There shouldn't be any weight coming
back to you, Chris. Right.
Let me see how you're pulling them back.
All right.
So,
as I said, right, I get projected out.
You get projected out. Okay? So, there
should never be weight that's coming
back to me. And when I had him let it
loose, I let it loose going forward.
Okay? Because he is going forward and
sitting down hanging himself. Okay? But
you can see now, okay, that's hard, but
it's the same skill. Just a smaller
window and multitasking of the yinyang.
Okay. But it's the same projection
skill.
So going back to like the kids, we'll
get them in the ballpark and then later
we show them the techniques. All right?
So, let's look at this technique. We
just have him sit down.
Okay. And we're not doing any of the
mechanics right now. We're working on
just the bar arm choke. The bar arm
choke is
every bit as lethal as a union.
You're going to take this forearm bone
right here and glide across the trachea.
You see that? We're not doing the el.
It's right here. You have to be busy
legal. That's why you don't see it in
internet.
This is a different hand. This is where
I'm at. Then this hand is waiter's hand.
And I do this cable grip here. Cut my
hands. Grab my thumb here.
This elbow
goes down and he's going to try to pull
it.
He now pulls it into his back. Does that
make sense? Come here like that. Nope.
He's going to pull it. He's going to try
to save his life.
So, I anchor this elbow. When he pulls
it, it goes into his back. You
understand? Okay. So, this is how we're
doing our get everything in place.
You're going to get good grip. I'm not
going to squeeze yet. I'm going to
anchor the elbow.
He's going to pull it.
You pull two hands. You should feel
pressure in the left elbow. Okay. Try.
You're on the You're on this portion on
the trachea, which is the wind. You're
going to grab your grips like this.
Yes. You're going to anchor the elbow
without tightening it. You got to keep
it loose. You got to give it a little.
We're testing the integrity of your
right elbow. Now he pulls down and that
should press into his back. Don't let
your elbow come up, Chris. Don't let the
right elbow come up. Go.
Got it. That's it. Now,
not like this. Like this.
Close your fingers together.
And the bottom hand. The bottom hand is
the elbow at hand. Okay. Here. There.
And this is what's pressing. Don't
tighten it yet. We're just testing this.
When she pulls, you should feel that
elbow going to work her back. Okay. She
pulls.
Good.
You got to You can't do it tight. You
got to do it loose. We can test the
elbow integrity.
Good.
That's the elbow check. That right elbow
into the butt. Yes. That's it. That's
it. There it is. Right there.
So, the choking area is the bone.
This part right here.
Move this like that.
Okay. Let me put you in. And then put
your thumbs together with your fingers.
That's what he holds on. And then we're
testing that. So you keep that down. And
now he pulls on there. And you just
pressing back.
Good.
Everyone's elbow stay in place. Okay.
So this this part feels anxious to us
when I tell you keep that loose. I see
how much space especially like a long
arm. You're like Dave is hanging off the
side. It doesn't matter because it's
over here.
That is the attack. You see that?
There's a lot there is a lot of room.
Well, I fill that room up with my
shoulder. That's what keeps his head
there. Don't fill it up with your elbow.
Okay. Down is on the fleshy part.
of my arm. It's not going to be
immediate resistance like the bone on
this. Okay,
here
shoulder. If you don't do that, people
can start trying to lift the elbow and
slip out the back there. Okay. So, you
feel the space
shoulder. You can get your head there,
too. You can't go out that way. Okay.
Now, you tricep pull. And we're still
testing the elbow. There's there's no
way he's going to get out of there and
no way he'll get out of there by the
time I touch that. Especially if I take
his balance and he's falling. Okay. So,
we just added to it. One, two, and then
we're still testing the elbow. It's
still loose. Okay. Try it.
Don't. Yeah. Give space. You want You
want this Virginia. This goes on the
throat. This goes on the Yes.
Now you just shrug your shoulder to keep
his head there and you tuck his head.
Anchor that elbow.
Good.
You're a little bit in the fleshy part.
your shoulder. Tuck your head and press
his head into that other shoulder. There
you go. Good.
It should be effortless.
You are got to get the bone against it.
Yeah. Don't Don't turn it.
Your elbow should not be down.
Okay, we're just testing the elbow.
Good. Tuck your shoulder. Tuck your
head. Tuck your head so you can't
squeeze it around.
There you go.
Okay, just once each part. Okay.
You cannot choke with your bicep. They
burn out. Okay. You don't you don't
choke by squeezing your your bicep back
into him. The choke that I did, he hung
himself. Okay. So, that's where the
initial boom repression is on the on the
trachea. Does that make sense? Okay.
But to obey this rule that I'm not
pulling this in and I'm not lengthening
it. That takes weight too is I will feel
myself with that pond. Okay. So here's
that here's that pressure. I got it
right on the edge. Right on the edge.
And I just start swelling. Take it off.
And you'll feel that without me moving
is tightening.
Okay. Does that make
Okay.
Right. Because the pressure falls and
the tandem swells. So that tandem is now
pushing on on him. Okay. Um and so I
don't ever burn the the choke out. So
again to do this
I get everything in place. Everything's
in place. Okay. I don't use my bicep. I
start to release.
Okay. He'll feel it pressing and he
that's where he safely should
do it. Tap out, okay? Because we don't
want to damage each other. But you
should feel a pressure change on your
throat from the pressure change. Okay?
Get everything in place. There's no
space. You're on the edge of no space.
Then you start relaxing.
Pressurizing your own body.
I'm going to move this a little. You
have to be perpendicular to the target.
That's where you want to be. Now, shrug
your shoulder against this head. Press
here. Pull that down.
Now, here is where
you don't let me push you over. You
understand? Okay.
Release the tension.
Okay.
So for example
um
again go back a lot of us don't think is
legal now we see aggressive um
but this would be one of those things
like from a peace officer use force law
if I could dump him on his
not reacting to shock him. If I could
shot him, I could break his trade. All
all those things at the same level of
course is all serious bod injury/
second point you can see I can take this
force engineer and do something totally
freaking different, right? Um
which is why it's import that I'm in
certain areas
in certain ways. So, we talked about how
important being in the right place at
the right time. Okay.
If ad
for whatever reason
goes south,
you're in the back.
A lot better options are back there than
trying to find this thing that you're
losing. You should you lost it. you
should go to the next technique. Okay?
And the transition should be so
seamlessly that no one would ever know
watching that you had in mind. Okay?
That's how seamless. So in order to be
that seamless in our fluidity,
our body itself has to be as neutral as
possible until initiative is achieved.
Okay? So, in other words, if I get
behind you and I start to rotate you, I
I got you not here, right? In other
words, but if for whatever reason, I
don't know, you changed your height, you
see, because your when you felt your
center getting tipped this way, remember
that originally turned your your angle
like that and you you dropped your
weight. It was like boom, right? You
dropped your weight. I merged with that
energy. Boom. Send your center out.
Boom. And you hung yourself. Okay? as
opposed to you drop your weight and I'm
trying to turn you. I'm now contesting.
This is why for example I was saying
don't don't get to the back in on me.
Han me will be found after you've gained
the initiative of the kazushi. Okay. Um
and again we'll point out how
advantageous the back is. Um, you can
think of it like for us, you know, we
give it give everything a freaking
tactical word painted black. So, it's
tactical now. Um, some company made a
joke. They would paint rocks black and
they would call it tactical rock.
You could buy it for your other cop
friends. So, technical. Um, so we call
the back the position of bandage.
You That's where you want to be. And
it's totally different from being
slightly off to the side. Okay. Um, so
here we have this technique that only
will function from straight on the back.
Won't function from straight off the
side.
All right. Um, questions, comments,
observations.
Um, the very last choke there was no
mechanical in your arm and I don't know
what it was, but
It's like some something swelled up.
Yeah. In the back of me or in front of
me or both and I just kind of got like I
said there was no Yeah. It was just
cuz that does that happen. You've seen
me do it in another way where like I had
Why did you punch punch at me from that
swollen position, right? Or ski at me,
right? doesn't mean I'm going to let you
ever punch me or that's my defense, but
it's a way of confirming that it's
there. Here it's put to a use um to help
you know constrict things um when you
start flexing
a lot of times you're getting smaller,
you see, until the pressure now now you
start to set that pressure up. Um
but in that meantime, those muscles that
are not necessary and aren't even in the
choke. They're fatiguing out. So, you
enter into the fatigue cycles really
quickly. What we teach
in in law enforcement is um like I don't
know. So, let me let me fill you in. So,
in um BJA they'll talk I don't even know
what they call it. I don't know if that
was a law enforcement nucleus.
But I know that I've heard like Henry
and Grayson talk about this. You get
them tired. They start to get tired. And
in BJJ that conventional wisdom, it's
like a minute. People kind of fight hard
for a minute. Um, and what we have found
on the street is probably because we're
not really dealing with highly trained
people or if we are dealing with highly
trained people,
they're also high or drawn things like
this. So, they're not at their physical
peak. So, the fatigue cycle is actually
about 10 to 15 seconds that dude peters
out. Okay. Well, the same thing goes for
you. in those high adrenaline fights
like you you will peter out really fast
if you're doing maximum effort on
anything. Um
that kind of goes into like even foot
pursuit. So like in the movie in the
movies you see the cops running
everyone's running and we don't do that
because when you catch that guy you're
going to have to fight. So we do more
like I think it's called persistence
hunting country. You just kind of keep
eyes on it. That guy peters out because
he's high on meth or whatever. And then
I'll wrestle with the guy that already
put himself in the fatigue cycle kind of
thing. But it takes uh emotional
intelligence, spiritual maturity to not
get angsted up and start flexing
unnecessarily.
So um the way to not do it is with the
sound techn
invented that. This is what this is the
way they always do it. So, if you go
back, like I'm sure you've seen some
older videos
of all our Japanese derived grappling
arts or even the Chinese arts, you'll
see that and the dude is choked out and
sometimes you don't even see the choke.
Uh, and part of that is that you don't
see the naga actually doing any of the
squeezing or anything. Um, or you might
have seen fights where the guy lets go
at him and the ref is wondering what
happened and then he's out, right? You
see all that kind of and that's just
proper technique. It's not magic. It's
just improper technique has become
common place now.
It's not
um
just like that that the coy projection
of their of their center out into the
hanging. It's not it's the same exact
thing
but it's more complicated because the
angle is more different and I'm busy
doing opposed to just that simple thing.
As far as the pulse goes, it's exactly
the same.